[Musique]
vite vite vite j'avais tout le monde est
pressé ladite 18th en dépêchant vite
vite vite dans l'eau déchaînant
dépêchons-nous allez aimer année tout
est prêt ça y est sous les bagages ni va
vous êtes prêts à les prêts sont prêts
sont l'heure tourne et c'est parti enfin
presque partout
[Musique]
oh là là là là qu'elle ment on n'est pas
arrivé au les enfants non ne commençait
pas votre comédie
[Musique]
nous pas question de s'arrêter on est
pressé
[Musique]
ralalala on perd du temps et l'autoroute
est complètement bouché
on en impôts des heures je sens que je
vais craquer
[Musique]
il
je crois que les petits what what ou
vont prendre les choses en main
[Musique]
tout le monde sont là de repos on va
vous montrer quelque chose eh oui il
n'ya pas que l'autoroute
s'il ya trop de monde
emprunter les petites routes et au
passage profitez en pour admirer la
campagne
allez c'est gratuit aujourd'hui à lévis
et oui pour tout le monde
bonjour couchant
[Musique]
comme ils sont mignons un pardon du
fromage mais nous merci
[Musique]
et puis on petit bouquet et les enfants
peuvent jouer sur l'herbe
[Musique]
allez maintenant prenez votre temps et
bon voyage
[Musique]
et papa soit c'est bien retenu la leçon
que maintenant il s'arrête toutes les 5
minutes et il fait le guide vous pouvez
ignorer la mirabelle dessin
architectural du portail de cet édifice
qui par rapport à un portail qui
constitue sans doute est cet art est et
sera un sacré papa soit c'est quand même
plus sympa de voyager comme ça
vous aussi faites connu
[Musique]
et au revoir merci à toronto et what
what où tu pour dire bonjour tous demain
[Musique]
tiens je te dis ni où on est et vous
vous avez trouvé
regardez bien oui et elle n'allait pas
mais où vas-tu encore du mont ventoux a
tout tué a l'intention de visiter tous
les pays
m
encore est bien avec toi en voyage
rapidement en route
[Musique]
k
vous reconnaissez j'espère
[Musique]
allez hop à nous voir encore un petit
peu plus loin tiens tiens tiens tiens ça
me rappelle quelque chose ça oui je ne
connais bien ce pays
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui a ou à tour tous qu'est ce
que tu as vu mais qu'est ce qu'il fait
mais lui c'est utile pour tous
mais dans tous les pays on me c'est une
manie
[Musique]
quoi
vous aussi et c'est pour construire ça
que vous détruisez vos jolies maisons
[Musique]
eh bien elle va être belle la terre sont
tous les pays se ressemblent si tous les
pays sont pareils
tu as raison à tous à tous on ne va pas
les laisser faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en trente ans
eh bien
[Musique]
et oui les tokyoïtes voit-on
reconstruise c'est bien sûr dans le
style de chaque pays
[Musique]
et voilà chaque pays a son caractère et
tous mis les uns aux autres ils forment
la terre
au revoir à tous à tous et merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
et oh
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
au couple
avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
pays
[Musique]
oui
et bédié et du bien impossible non c'est
pas du brouillard et c'est bien fumer on
se tire respira s'applique la gorge au
credo chien se sent mode
[Musique]
hu à tous à tous les niveaux il va faire
semblant d'être intoxiqué
[Musique]
[Rires]
elle
[Musique]
et patrons regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas grave - bah il aurait quand
même eu un besoin d'un bon bol d'air
[Musique]
a créé de chien vaut mieux attendre
c'est pas fini
[Musique]
cet incident ne va pas passer inaperçue
le soir même à la télévision et le
lendemain matin à la une tous les autres
rôles l'année c'est terrible c'est vrai
il ya de fumer dans cette usine il faut
absolument alerter l'opinion et
souplesse c'est un scandale
il n'y a pas de fumée sans le pdg
convoqué il faut faire quelque chose ça
ne peut plus durer comme ça alors tondre
les employés de résine sont convoqués il
faut faire quelque chose ça ne peut plus
durer comme ça
regardez patron j'ai une idée allons-y
hommage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est top
c'est fini on peut y aller
[Musique]
et voilà c'est beaucoup mieux le ciel
est bleu maintenant et on peut même
faire une ronde autour des cheminées
puisqu'il n'y a plus de fumée au revoir
à toi ton inertie tient tant 11 ans -
quelle drôle de façon de voyager
ouais heureusement que les petits boîte
boîte auto ramène à la maison
je crains
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font du jardin
public
non ils construisent des tours de béton
à la place des gens qui t'ont soi mais
une seule fleur ne pourra jamais
remplacer tout un jardin d'ailleurs la
pauvre elle ne résiste pas longtemps
le grand patron non oui credo chien est
en colère les arbres du monde pour votre
dossier vous inquiétez pas on les a
remplacés par de magnifiques arbres en
béton mais ces arbres là ont des failles
qui font mal
[Rires]
à
[Musique]
lourd
allez les petits voient tout débarrasser
nous de ce béton
autour
et maintenant que le ménage effet
apporté les vrais arbres et s'il vous
plaît déroulé le tapis vert et de chef
fou de joie il a retrouvé son jardin et
tonton soit était pas un il regarde
pousser les fleurs
[Musique]
attendez ce n'est pas fini
et oui on construit de très belles
maisons
[Musique]
eh oui finalement c'est pas mal hein
alors c'est d'accord on fait comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention aux nombreux d'état met en
garde
c'est aussi doux qu'une carence au
revoir à tous à tous et merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh là là mais elle en fait du bruit
cette cuisine évidemment vous avez
compris calment un peu c'est une
fabrique d'avertisseurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
décidément c'est maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même le jardinier se plaint regardez ces
salades en mauvaise mine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc oui bien sûr c'est plus agréable
travailler dans le calme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'avec tous ces dérangements
on ne peut pas se concentrer chauffeur à
la maison c'est bien plus silencieux
kalinin ares 1 on va y rémédier
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
bonne idée ou à tout et tout si la
[Musique]
droite ou le tout un peu plus tard
devant le tribunal un credo chien aime
bien son sort
[Musique]
d'après vos chats n'aiment pas du tout
du goût des usines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui effectivement aussi chacun s'amuse à
faire tout le bruit que son voisin à la
vie devient rapidement infernal c'est
bien voilà tout le monde d'accord c'est
beaucoup plus sympathique de travailler
dans le calme
où
[Musique]
c'est le jardinier lui il est vraiment
ravi depuis que l'usiné fait plus le
bruit qu'il passe son temps assise dans
sa chaise longue à écouter pousser ses
salades
merci à tous à tout ça sent bon
il ya la soupe ce soir venu ma long
voile fonds vaf un effort
elle est très bonne cette soupe au même
instant au comptoir d'un café à ça ça
vous voulez mais qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est sûrement l'eau qui est mauvaise il
va faire dans l'analyse et
[Musique]
tenez regardez celle là alain drôle de
goût et ce n'est pas normal que l'on
soit mauvaise
il ya justement une usine de filtrage
qui la rend potable à nous voir à la
rivière mais qu'est ce qui se passe mais
elle est polluée
c'est scandaleux c'est l'usiné d'à côté
qui diverses toutes ces saletés
[Musique]
évidemment le directeur n'a rien voulu
entendre au wat où il faut faire quelque
chose absolument
[Musique]
oh
oui effectivement c'est pas beau vous
pouvez avoir entre vite parant au plus
pressé
les petits what our atouts s'occupe de
sauver les poissons
[Musique]
et maintenant à est et où on fabrique
une grille de filtrage et regarder la
rivière redevient propres
[Musique]
aupic
santé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo à toi ton et mi6 et bien il fait
très beau aujourd'hui on a une bonne
idée d'aller sur la plage
[Musique]
et qui va se baigner saisi ma chance et
qui va crier c'est ton choix
[Applaudissements]
potage ne faut pas se laisser aller
n'est ce pas tonton soit
[Applaudissements]
oh non cette fois les autres chiens sont
à l'étroit loin et voient toi ton
attention comme un chien se noie
d'ailleurs toi
ma
[Musique]
tiens pétroliers
et qu'est ce qu'ils font ouais mais je
rêve mais c'est une marée noire
quand les inconscients et on doit le
credo chien qui vont baigner et lui le
commandant prix qu'est ce qu'il va
réagir enfin attention soir le plein de
couteaux voix il ne peut plus nager
tiens bon trait de chiens vas-y ne lâche
pas
dupas
et tout ça cause un commandant qui est
complètement fou sous sa casquette
[Musique]
le chien
et moi c'est la scarlatine mais non
celle à mazout in quand même le
commandant s'est aperçu de sa bêtise
il est un peu par des pompes aspirantes
watts watteau tu es un génie mais les
marins ont l'air malin tiens
s'ils n'avaient pas tous ali et bien il
ne serait pas là en train de nettoyer
[Musique]
merci à toi tout
tiens où sommes nous mort aux états unis
je reconnais la statue de la liberté et
de quoi discuter mais ces trois là ils
veulent construire des immeubles mais il
n'y a plus de place à non tout on n'est
pas d'accord
credo chanot plusieurs années qu'ils ont
une étrange idée
ils veulent prolonger la terre en
comblant la mer et de cette façon ils
ont de la place pour construire de
nouveaux immeubles
[Musique]
et voilà les immeubles se construisent
mais qu'est-ce qui le reprend en commun
heure et en face de l'autre côté de
l'océan
que se passe-t-il mais ils font pareil
[Musique]
mais réfléchissez mais l'océan va
disparaître oui évidemment on peut
traverser à pied
regardez l'eau monte
voilà ce que c'est que de vouloir
prendre la place des océans
la nature se défend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
voilà l'une des droites ou a tous
rapprochés le soleil de la terre pour
faire évaporer l'eau regardez bien
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon là il faut que la mère reprenne sa
place
[Musique]
et bien voilà c'est bien mieux comme ça
allez bonne traversée et soyez
raisonnables respecter la nature
au revoir aux toitures merci après le
déjeuner en débarrasse la table on met
les restes dans la poubelle la poubelle
dans la rue
tiens papa souhaitons tous voient je
vous ai boire maintenant vous allez vous
comme ça mais qu'est ce que vous faites
non mais ça va pas enfin vous n'êtes pas
généré évidemment ça attire les crédos
chien toujours la recherche d'un hors
jeu voilà bah tiens ça donne des idées
aux autres
[Musique]
tout le monde fait pareil pollueurs
encore un mais que fait-il mais il met
le feu
[Musique]
on voit tout tu es là fais quelque chose
je t'en supplie
[Musique]
oh non vous n'allez pas recommencer tout
de même
[Musique]
enfin
des charges interdite c'est compris
[Musique]
bon maintenant retrouvons les autres
podiums puisque vous avez sali
maintenant il va falloir nettoyer
aller au travail et que tout cela
disparaît ensuite les ordures que l'on a
récupéré on les emporte dans une usine
là elles sont soigneusement brûlé et ça
ne laisse pas de trace
la campagne quand même plus belle comme
ça non
et si vous voulez vraiment faire plaisir
à watou fait encore un petit effort à la
place de la décharge sauvage arranger
l'endroit pour que les gens viennent
pique-niquer propre roman
[Musique]
au revoir voit tous à tous merci
il y en a qui ont la chance de ne pas
avoir besoin de fusées pour aller jouer
dans l'espace
moi ça me plairait bien
et regardez qu'est ce que c'est cette
planète hoth grise
[Musique]
regarde là
aves au spatial
il se dirige à cette planète suivant le
[Musique]
lacet engins modernes c'est pas pratique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne sais pas comment se nomme cette
planète mais moi je l'appellerai un
poubelle
[Musique]
regardez
une montagne
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh quelle est cette chose
ce alors créé deux chiens mais qu'est ce
que tu fais ici
[Applaudissements]
voilà chers
oui bien sûr au crochet qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
attention vous deux et bien cette
caravane c'est un véritable musée des
ordures des camions
oui mais ça recommence encore dégarnir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les boîtes où il faut nettoyer tout ça
et les petits voient tous font la chaîne
pour brûler toutes les ordures regardez
petit petit la montagne de saleté
diminue et figurez-vous que sous le tas
d'ordures on découvre de l'herbe et des
fleurs
[Musique]
quoi encore des camions et ma parole il
n'y a que ça sur cette planète
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant ce sont des chauffeurs
comme chez nous je ne comprends plus
rien je me présente je viens de france
et moi des états unis mais où sommes
nous j'ai peur de comprendre
or pauvre astronautes
le shaq est dur pour eux et oui bonjour
à toi fan bonjour à tous la liberté
bonjour muraille de chine
bonjour le kilimandjaro et oui bonjour
la terre je vous connais mieux quand il
prend pas au revoir à tous à tous et
merci
comme tous les mercredis après-midi
maman soit emmène ses enfants promenades
et comme tous les mercredis après-midi
le marchand de glaces est au rendez vous
mais les papiers et les bâtons on
n'hésite pas par terre évidemment après
avoir mangé une glace
on a une petite soit au nom pas les
boîtes par terre encore une fois
[Musique]
ce qu'ils vivent et de chocolat sont
complets enfin sont toujours aussi sale
c'est en faisant bon eh bien puisque ça
leur appartient
on va leur rapporter mois mais qu'a fait
sam est il possible être aussi sale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pauvre ton doigt pour une fois qu'il n'a
rien fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais cela rappelle quelque chose à ma
montjoie et oui tout cela vous
appartient les seuls coupables c'est à
toi t'en sors de ta cachette et vient
tout expliquer allez ensuite et nous on
va vous montrer
[Musique]
en effet c'est tout simple il suffit de
déposer des poubelles
voyons ce que vont faire ces oies goûts
rock
ah bravo à france
[Musique]
on continue c'est bien
et voilà un petit geste et tout est
propre
[Musique]
des méduses
allez on recommence avec tout le monde
on va lancer une opération lille propres
[Musique]
bravo ou à tout l'été et merci
il
quel charmant petit village avec sa
grand place sa mairie son église son bar
tabac et ses joueurs de pétanque au et
voilà une charmante petite bergère
il ya également son papa jean monsieur
[Musique]
en fait c'est un coin très sympathique
voilà une tout à coup comme ça des
affaires tous les regarde moi ça c'est
joli ça avec ses couleurs sa super non
allez tu comprends coucou c'est la pub
c'est faux grèce et tout ça quoi
allez on est d'accord signé la merci à
l'esa licoco on s'appelle et ensuite
vous
[Musique]
à tokyo on va faire des affaires regarde
ça c'est magnifique ça non mais t'as vu
qu'elle aime pas et hop on est d'accord
c'est nier la met à l'essai mais quand
on s'appelle et ouzbeks ou lendemain
matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce que c'est laid
[Musique]
non c'est vraiment trop moche
le nom le village ne ressemble plus à
rien ils sont le maire fasse quelques
chambres
[Musique]
non
messmer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien voilà c'est mieux de la
publicité
d'accord mais il faut qu'elle soit bien
placé et allez arrête de râler coco
téléphone moi et on ira pique-niqué
merci à tous à tous
[Musique]
et nous
et